walker bueller making his fifth start of
this season the era right now is 521 but
if you're looking for reason to
have optimism still look at where it was
after four games last year and then what
follow he had a 5 40 after the slow ramp
up in spring training
took off from there and was a national
big all-star he knows back to the
fastball gets it by story strike three
that's 2019 after four starts
vintage walker bueller right there
that's a slider that's ripped into right
center field base hit peterson wins the
battle and gets extra bases to open the
knife
here's his payoff turner lines about to
center field that's down to bayes hill
he'll stop peterson at third he had to
be certain that he could drop
in front of hillary and they've got him
cornered with one away here's bellinger
trying to build off of uh what he did in
seattle homering in both games there
ballinger slices the liner to left
center field base hit that'll split the
gap and he's done it again to gray
peterson in the score easily on a double
from bellinger and the dodgers lead in
the first
and there it is on cue the rockies
charlie blackman with the first hit of
the night that'll bring up nolan he
chases again
and didn't nick what part of the uh
seems on that that does it for the
rockies in the fourth as bueller gets
his seventh
strikeout of the night so it remains one
nothing as pollock yanks one in the air
to left sends topia back out
off the wall ricochets right to tapia
police at second with a stand-up double
to open the fourth
good sense based it to right
police had to wait to make sure it would
drop evil sending him home with a throw
going into second
an rbi single for matt beatty makes it
two nothing
three balls two strikes runner stays
as taylor finds a base hit into right
field
three hits in a row for the dodgers to
open the fourth
taylor singles to right baby holds it
second up to seeger with two gone
seeger rips one down the line a fair
ball that are rattled around the corner
babies in to score easily taylor right
on his heels headed for the plate and a
two-run
double for corey seeger and the dodgers
take advantage here in the fourth
leading
four nothing two balls in a strike
the pitch is swung on and hit in the air
right side towards the line blackman
over to have a look makes a slide in
foul territory and he comes up with a
beautiful catch
charlie blackman puts an end to the
rally but the dodgers score
three times in the fourth delivers 2-2
ballinger swats one over short base hit
to left
and it's starting to look more and more
believable more and more trustworthy
that cody bellinger is hitting his
stride
off of murphy ricochet into short right
and muncie saying
finally
[Music]
infield single for max monsieur who's
had a lot of bad breaks
one two got him swinging with a fastball
boy they've stood no shot against that
fast spot up in the zone
bueller with his 10th strikeout one gone
in the six time ever
the fastball is being thrown there's a
base hit for butera on the slider
slider cutter the fastball is being
thrown
less than it's ever been thrown before
in major league baseball
this is bounce through the whole base
hit for tapia
and butera will stop at second but the
rockies down by
four so back-to-back singles in the six
and trevor story coming up this time the
rockets have had a runner at second
and this ball's hit hard to the right
side butera
is around third he's coming home and he
will score it's 4-1
tapia goes first to third trevor story
coming through his 16th rbi
six innings for mueller dave roberts
over to give him a congratulations on a
good night
a little massage too season high 11
k's for walker as taylor lifts about a
deep left center field in the first
pitch of the ending
off the base of the wall he's chugging
his way around
second will hang there with the lead off
double
[Applause]
austin barnes drives in a run the
dodgers take the run right back lead 5-1
a pop fly into shallow center field
seeger and muncie are out there it's
corey seeger to finish off an uneventful
ninth inning in a 5-1 dodger win their
ninth
out of the last 10. every department was
really good
especially walker bueller